[Music]
from technology that helped us conquer
Everest to a cruise missile the science
museum group has a collection of over
seven million items today I will
discover how Star Wars helped a
generation of children to undergo brain
scan and another story in the stores but
these are actually can I touch the label
you're allowed to touch the label these
these are actually labeled Jedi helmet
which is amazing these aren't actual
Star Wars props I'm guessing no they're
not but they're actually named after
their helmets worn by own people with me
returning the Jedi film in 1983 so as
you can guess they date from the early
1980s
what were they useful so they're
actually used for really early MRI
imaging specifically for children so
these came from Hammersmith Hospital who
donated them to us in the early 1990s
early MRI the problem was that with
smaller children's Frank's you couldn't
get the image quality that you had from
adults so what they did was they
searched we made a radio aerial Wow
I thought I was gonna be water going
through that tubing or something no
they're entirely copper and they would
have been connected to a computer there
so the way that MRI works is that giant
magnets changed the spin of atoms in our
bodies and then the signals get picked
up and made into pictures so these just
helped enhance the images so the machine
that came with these as well was
actually if I really beige looked really
kind of almost prototype II itself so
you can imagine a child going in there
what the hell would make that better
well I think because they're called Jedi
helmets kids would go all right I can
put this on and I can be a Jedi and the
team actually experimented a lot on
their own children and so they knew the
technology was safe but they needed to
know this what some of these are clearly
kind of just rigged together because
that looks like a colander from a
kitchen it is there and some of my
favorite ones are actually the ones that
say things like astronaut what did these
become were they did they just become
obsolete because technology got better
or is there still so these prototypes
actually went on to become commercially
available but as machines got stronger
in the magnets got more power you didn't
necessarily need something as well
so what's so special about these for you
and so when I first think Hansen perm
many years ago now I when I heard the
word Jedi helmet I thought it's because
Jedi's could read minds rather than
thing but it kind of is it is in a way
and that's what I kind of love about
these is that they come with their own
stories but then we can bring our own
stories to them as well
[Music]